times like these show how
important it is for science to be
visible the museum of natural history in
berlin
has found a vivid and special approach
to science communication
a scientific variety show david ziegler
the show's project lead explains the
concept
our contribution to the berlin science
week is the variety show
glitzan and deng it's a science variety
show
so we bring artists and scientists on
stage together to perform a show
which has elements of circus which has
elements of theater
and is themed by a scientific topic
this year our topic is slimy because our
show deals with the
animal group of mollusks which consist
of snails octopuses and clams
the new show wants to inspire people to
be curious
and create a fascination for nature we
want to make an
impact on the future by finding a new
way of speaking about science
and this new way should less be guided
by the principles of
scientific report but more by the
principles of storytelling and by the
principles of art
the way we speak with our friends and
family i think we have a great
chance of improving our communication
about science if we show our emotions if
we show our passions
because this will give us a different
channel to the broad public
and to the people talking about which
impact science makes for our everyday
lives and how it helps us to make the
world better
[Music]
a great challenge in our project is
finding a common ground
for the artists and the scientists to
work together
because in a way they're very similar
because they both deal with
human creativity but in a way they're
also very different because the way they
express this creativity
and the methods they use the every
everyday life are very different
a challenge of our project is finding a
productive use of the frictions and the
interference that this creates